you know yesterday we had clips from
this Texas Tribune event in which
California governor Gavin Newsom was
striking the exact right tone and moral
Clarity when it comes to Republican
Governor Ron desantis's Martha's
Vineyard immigrant stunt well Gavin
Newsom correctly pointing out this is
disgusting this is using people this is
bullying and I'm against this I'm
against this and I believe that he did a
great job of using the right language
and tone that Democrats need to use
let's not shy away from the fact that
the left does have the moral High Ground
on most issues
um when compared to these completely
amoral right-wingers well I have another
clip from that very same event and it's
of Transportation secretary Pete Budaj
and again I've mentioned yesterday I
mentioned there are certain people right
now in the Democratic Party
that know how to talk about these issues
Gavin Newsom is one of them I've talked
about Katie Porter to some degree we've
talked about Stacy Abrams and Jamie
Raskin Pete boot Edge is also one of
those folks and here is Pete talking
about the Ron DeSantis stunt we need
more Democrats talking about issues in
this way take a look at this
you don't have a solution right
where can easily come here to census was
in Congress where was he when they were
debating immigration reforms
what have any of these people done to be
part of the solution
so you know I get if you're after
attention
it's one thing to
call attention to a problem
when you have a course action as some of
the folks here speaking up about an
issue exercising their first amendment
rights have not or an in elected office
it's another to just call attention to a
problem because the problem
is actually more useful to you than the
solution and that helps you call
attention to yourself correct
um
that's what's going on and the problem
of course it's one thing if that was
just people being obnoxious but human
beings are being impacted by that you
flee a communist regime in Venezuela you
come here
and then somebody tricks you with
somebody using Florida taxpayer money
for some reason tricks you into going
from Texas to Massachusetts it's it's
it's not just ineffectual it is hurting
people in order to get attention
it is morally depraved what was done in
other words we need more Democrats
talking about issues in this way what
Gavin Newsom and mayor Pete Secretary of
Transportation he'll always be mayor
Pete to some degree what Newsom and
mayor P capture here is the essence of
how bad faith these Republicans are
I joke around about you know this guy
has upper management written all over
him there is some sense that Pete Buddha
judge is not going to Peak at Secretary
of Transportation because he is really
good at this and unfortunately we still
have a situation where people judge him
for who he loves the fact that he's
married to a guy
I believe that that is going to be a
diminishing impediment for mayor Pete
over time I don't know how soon and I
don't know how quickly but what's
interesting is I actually have some sort
of Center center right I have some sort
of like socially liberal but typically
Republican voting friends for fiscal
reasons who you know they like Mitt
Romney for example they they kind of
like McCain
uh who like Pete not because they agree
or disagree so much with his social
views or his economic views but because
they feel that he strikes the right tone
and brings the right energy and is of an
interesting generation to be in a
position of power and so I actually
believe that particularly as quite
frankly overt homophobia hopefully
continues to diminish I think Pete
butterjudge has a real shot at uh higher
office than where he is now which is
Secretary of Transportation doing a
really good job there and I'm glad to
see more Democrats actually talking
about issues in this way it's necessary
we have the moral High ground there's no
reason to lose the rhetoric game it's
just we have to know how to talk about
the issues and some of these guys and
gals absolutely do
one of our sponsors today is BusyBox
child I know that there are many parents
in our audience this is for you BusyBox
child offers really great subscription
boxes for kids filled with sensory toys
that will help your toddler to
Elementary age child stay off screens
and do some really interesting stuff
technology use by kids is at an all-time
high especially after the pandemic
playing off of screens is really
critical for development for cognitive
development social emotional well-being
for kids it's an ideal opportunity for
parents to engage with kids as well
Carolyn is the founder of BusyBox child
she's a mom and a child clinical
psychologist who designs all the boxes
that you receive busy box child offers
monthly sensory kits with different
themes for each season or you can get a
monthly sand bin subscription for hours
and hours of fun check out their mini
jars and mini kits for playtime on the
go BusyBox child is a small business
that supports the David Pacman show
support them go to
busyboxchild.com and use the code Pacman
for 10 off the link is down below